With next generation technologies,
we have the ability to replace the
petroleum we use today in our vehicles
with advanced biofuels.
Those technologies require years to
develop and literally hundreds of
millions of dollars of investment in
order for that investment to occur.
In order for that R and d to actually
happen,
there needs to be a conventional
biofuels industry from which to evolve.
Today's conventional biofuels industry
provides exactly that platform and we
anticipate over the next decade that
that transformation will occur and that
next generation,
sustainable biofuels will become the
norm rather than the exception.